hello everybody and welcome to another
Advanced flipping guide today I'm going
to be showing you how I flip high volume
items as so any item that has 100,000
million plus traded a day I consider to
be a high volume item I'm going to go
through a bit of a workflow of how I
determine if a item is good because a
lot of people know uh I mean like Z
scales runes there's a lot of pretty
wellknown flipping items that are high
volume uh but I'll show you how I
determine if the item's actually going
to be good at a particular moment and um
just anything else related to flipping
high volume items all right let's jump
into it all right so the first part is
actually the easiest and that is just
finding an item now the item doesn't
have to be good you just have to find an
item to work with and then we can
determine how good it is from there and
if you need to look for another one
after uh so to start off what I normally
do is I go to uh run scaves top 100 most
traded items now of course there are
more than 100 items that would be
considered high volume in the game uh
but these are all pretty good and it's a
good place to start uh from there uh if
you have access to G tracker which is a
website that sponsors me and uh is a gr
exchange tracking tool in itself uh they
do have access to a high volume tab uh
which is extremely useful has a ton of
different ideas that aren't just on the
most traded page you can see here the
diamond bolt e are at the top with
approximately a 32 GP margin again
you're going to want to recheck that but
it's good for ideas uh link will be in
the description for G tracker all right
so let's just say we're going to check
the diamond bolt e we'll go ahead go
into our grand exchange and uh buy and
sell a diamond bolt e all right so we're
going to buy it for 574 that seems weird
and we're going to sell it
for
554 all right so you're thinking that
this probably good margin uh but you
don't want to base whether you're going
to flip an item just off of the margin
you definitely want to go ahead and have
a look more into the item so let's go
ahead we're going to hop on the G
tracker for this it is going to be free
all the tools for the most prime using
NG tracker are free all right so we're
going to look up the diamond bolt e so
we know this is going to be a highly
traded item it was already in the list
there buying quantity 40,000 selling
quantity 22,000 uh if we look how many
are traded a day 1.4 million that is
definitely a high volume item so the
most important thing we're going to want
to look at is the histor IAL price here
um if you have the free membership you
can have a look at the week now you can
see something weird is going on here it
spiked up to an extremely high amount
and um just in the last 3 hours so while
the margin is good on this item the risk
I would not take the risk for this
anyway I don't think it's worth it even
though the margin is decent we're going
to skip on this item so let's go ahead
and look for another item here uh let's
just look at this highly traded items
page here let's go with the death rune
tend to have a pretty decent margin on
them death Rune all right so we bought
for 390 and uh we're going to that seems
really high
too oh sorry we bought it for 350 and we
sold it for 327 so again looks like a
really good margin let's go have a quick
look at um G tracker again and this is a
really important step that a lot of
people forget is to actually check the
item with some third party software uh
well that sounds a little extreme but
anyway using a website like this to
check the historical values uh cuz again
this does look quite a bit higher so
what was our Buy price
again 327 so that's what we're going to
be buying it for so don't worry too much
about the sell price cuz what your
purching is for is what where you stand
to lose from
327 is definitely a bit higher than
normally is but you're not it's been
going up like this for half of the day
already so I think this is probably a
reasonable amount of risk for the amount
of margin we could potentially get so
we'll go ahead and buy this item so
327 uh the limit on death runes is 10K
again if you have access to G tracker
there should be a uh limit displayed
here 10,000 if not you can look it up on
the wiki it's available online all right
another important uh tip I can give you
is when you're buying high margin items
you definitely want to buy the buying
limits worth but take off like 10 or so
uh cuz you don't want to actually hit
the buy limit cuz you will not be able
to recheck the item later so the final
check I go through after I've determined
an item is safe to flip has a good
margin on it is just finally to see how
it compares to other items and the way I
do that is by determining a ratio now
this ratio is going to correspond to how
much it costs to obtain one GP in profit
so if you you're spending 50 GP and
you're getting one GP in profit compared
to another item where you're spending
100 GP and you're getting one coin in
profit the first one is going to be
better
that's how I personally like to rank
different items especially when they're
in the same category like a high volume
item they're all going to be trading the
same they don't have a lot different
differentiating themselves besides um
this ratio in my opinion so to start off
to get the ratio uh you're going to
start by getting the margin of the item
so if we have a bow string as an example
here 133 minus 131 is going to be two 2
GP on each bow string uh from there
you're going to take the uh price that
you sold the item at or bought it at
least this top part of the bow string
image here is 131 you're gonna take the
lower of the prices divide it by the
margin which in this case is two giving
you a ratio of 65.6 GP or it cost us
about 65 GP to earn one GP in profit I
would consider this to be okay not
terrible not that great so this is how I
rank the different ratios if you have a
ratio that's less than 10 10 that would
be insanely good although you do have to
keep in mind that cheap items like say
the fire Rune or Earth Rune they'll have
an insane ratio on them but it's because
they're so cheap so I wouldn't really
consider an item unless it's over 20 30
40 GP mostly uh if it's between 10 and
20 GP ratio uh that is going to be very
good 20 to 50 is good 50 to 100 is kind
of the average item in 100 plus probably
wouldn't bother with uh but not
necessarily
all right so while we were gone uh we
did manage to successfully flip our
death runes now we didn't sell them for
350 didn't expect to but we'll go ahead
collect it and uh see what kind of
profit we're looking at 33 37 W is
3267 70k in profit there we go all right
so now we'll go ahead and determine how
good the flip was so we'll take our uh
price we sold it at take off the price
we bought it at that's going to give us
our margin margin we got seven GP on
each item now we're going to take the
price we bought the items at 327 and
divide it by the margin which is seven
that's going to give us a uh
46 point ratio now what that essentially
means is I have a little graph open here
that I showed you earlier uh now it cost
us 46 coins to get one GP back from the
item if we have a look at our the way I
kind of distribute it it's in the good
category decent a little bit above
average and uh pretty happy with that
flip all right so we're going to do
three more example Flips For You just
three kind of different items uh but all
high volume all right so let's start off
with the astral Rune I already checked
the margin here but we'll do it again
for you
quickly uh so we bought it for 194 and
we're going to sell it
for 189 so that is a 5gp margin uh let's
go ahead and quickly look at the GE
tracker graph uh Astro Rune is here
again we're buying it for
correct all right so we'll go down here
to the earliest data possible all right
so yes it is spiking uh but it's not
abnormally High by any means and um this
item will trade quickly enough for us to
hopefully get this profit before the
price changes too much so go ahead buy
10K these
take off about 5 to 10 all right the
last thing we want to do here again for
the astral Rune is just check the ratio
this just make sure it's decent so we
have a 5gp ratio which is uh 194 minus
189 it's 5 GP so we're going to take 189
divide by 5 uh giving us
37.8 uh which is uh pretty good we have
a little uh chart here it's in the good
category decent
let's move on to another item
here uh what else I look up Adam and
dart going to buy it for
172 and sell it
for 166 looks like a very good margin on
it let's go ahead have a quick look at G
tracker actually we have it open here
Perfect all right so it looks like uh
averages around 170 five is kind of a
higher point but not too bad and we
could look to buy it for 166 I think
that's a pretty decent price go ahead
and buy uh 10k of these I believe is a
limit let's go ahead and recheck the
limit here actually 11,000 all right
we'll go for
10995 at
166 looks good all right another item I
want to try doing is actually free to
play uh so we'll try the soft clay uh
looks like it's more expensive than it
normally would be right now soft clay
200 and is selling
for 170 so it's a 30 GP margin on it
right now of course we're going to go
have a quick look at G tracker I think
I'm prepared to take a bit of a riskier
item here uh but let's have a look at
the
price so the last little while it is
going up to 200 and 170 we're looking to
buy it for 170 let's go ahead and do
that and the limit on the soft clay is
is not available so we'll go ahead and
just do around 10K take off some and
yeah we'll wait till these items have
bought and sold and we'll come back with
the results all right so we're back and
everything did manage to sell now we did
end up swapping out our uh soft clay for
you log still a freet to playay item so
you get the idea let's start with the
astal runes uh so unfortunately we
didn't nearly get the price uh that we
wanted that being said the crashing
price but they still stayed above uh
what we bought them for uh which is 189
and uh we still
profited 10K so not like that much but
we didn't lose any money so we kind of
helped uh prevent any loss there next up
the adamant darts extremely good sold
them for $1 179 and we bought them
for 166 so uh 1825 into 1968 that's
about 130k in profit off that flip took
about 15 minutes not that long last up
is ulog we uh sold them for 363 each and
we bought them for
356 very good for free to play um I
can't think of an easier way to make 60k
uh just from doing nothing so as you can
see all these uh flips were pretty
successful didn't lose any money uh cuz
we checked the items price beforehand
and uh made sure we you weren't buying
the item that had been spiking at the
time all right so let's go ahead and
just do a final price check here just to
see how much we made uh just some pretty
casual flips so
282k extremely easy I mean we have 30
mil but we only use like five and uh how
does this normally fit into my flipping
schedule you could say I usually come up
with 5 to 10 uh good high quality high
volume items that you can just uh put
fill up your offer slots with do the
flips and uh then repeat them in 4 hours
it's good to have at least six if you're
going to solely be flipping high volume
items and yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
the video maybe you learned something uh
if you did don't forget to subscribe to
my channel haven't said that a lot
recently and I will see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
a